yeah you don't live in my react there's
reality you don't know what it's like to
be gay or it's fine fine then make then
make it a rule that no straight white
man can pass any legislation that
relates to women gays blacks
transgenders good luck with your reform
I one of the biggest logical fallacies
we've talked about this quite a bit
before is the appeal to Authority
fallacy
so let me ask that question of the day
how often do you encounter this value in
your day to day like your political
conversation to pick any issue okay how
often does someone try to throw down the
trump card by pointing to an authority
other than you be it could be gender
street cred it could be race could be
scientific consensus point is how often
do you encounter people saying well you
couldn't possibly know X so you just
have to leave it to Y or trust this
person who wasn't here right now or
trust me because I have insert genitalia
a year or melanin how often do you
encounter I encountered so often rent
that it's it's gotten to the point where
we become desensitized so let me start
this off with some new videos from this
channel called Jubilee and the videos
are called middle ground and they're
designed to see if people from posing
ideologies can confine middle ground of
course so there's one there's LGBTQ
versus Christian there's black lives
matter versus lawn for there's some
something with Trump supporters abortion
it's important to note it's the exact
opposite have changed my mind it is
handpicked voices of opposition's very
leading questions and edited down so
that you see exactly what the video
producers want you to see it's the
opposite of raw but let's look at the
feminists and non feminists on gender
equality like abortion those who signed
the bill in the room with Trump they
were all white men I did not see a
single woman just doesn't matter if it's
a white woman woman about birth control
abortion health care everything and we
can't even have a say on it cuz they
won't even hear us like she points in
tandem okay so her her claim is men's
side Trump's abortion bill so but it's a
woman's issue here ago only women can
comment on abortion which brings us to
the real problem here I think with with
identity politics and this appeal to
Authority it's so wildly inconsistent
they can't even apply it correctly
themselves or even to themselves what's
it
examples okay so she talks right here
about abortion right so what I don't
know why these missions under sai-dono
men can have to make decisions for
abortion
okay Roby raid it was decided by man
right welcome do you want it you what
you want that gun will matter so it's
okay it's okay from an avenue in opinion
there this is the appeal to authority
fallacy there's not at all consistent
it's i don't know why these people are
deciding it unless they're deciding it
the way that you want to while we're
hitting some feminist issues guess who
signed into law the right for women to
vote men predominantly white men guess
guess who guess who created the rape
laws that you have and are predominantly
responsible for it implementing
sentencing for rapes the judges roll
back it was because white men instituted
them didn't have a problem with it then
right and even if she was correct in
that mostly men were the people that
were in that room at the time did she so
dense that she thinks those are the only
people involved in this decision there
were no advisors there wasn't Congress
that wasn't anybody else that contained
a group of women that were speaking for
control pills one too it's like you
shouldn't have sex with whoever you want
but don't use the magical pills of
pleasure
do we take that's a pill because a man
environment no by the way not even
speaking which hit the bell join up mug
club on our show every single night
lateral cut it become /mo club or watch
the live stream Thursdays at 8:00 p.m.
Eastern every single Thursday also you
can try for free
so here's another claim we often see
this it's not only with feminist black
lives matter right he's activist a
certified dinner these identity politics
perpetual victim they're just
professional victims as we call them so
they'll say a lot if you're white that
you need to step aside on racial issues
you've seen this time and time again and
my job is to show other white people
down when they want to interrupt
[Applause]
I'm not prejudiced I'm a Democrat I'm
accepting my job is to make sure that
they get that they have privilege and
until we shut our mouths and we listen
to those people who don't what I need
y'all to understand is this is not about
you sit down shut up and listen to the
people in need
oh you put oh that's that face serious
um I guess I would be wrong for so I
like the old white guy behind her who's
like I do i clap doin I don't know what
to do is grind or xizt or not what
people need to shut up by talking about
me Katie I'm confused it's not about us
who create a legislation to free the
slaves hmm well exclusively white men
enslave them that's not true it's also
relevant to the point would you would
you prefer that white men not free them
because they were white who's run the
Civil Rights Act largely white
Republican men right this is something
again not entirely white Republican men
it's important does that change the
point do you want to overturn those laws
let me throw some more information that
you hear so today white conservatives
who want to whittle away at the welfare
state because it's grown too big and
obviously daddy's balloon work you too
being racist yeah most insensitive
people on the planet too but even then
who created the welfare state poverty
well first date cause the American
people are 22 trillion dollars over the
past 50 years look at the model Cities
program so it shows you that white men
don't even exist in a monolith it's more
than twenty one enemy when it's
convenient for your argument but but
also this heroic monolith when decisions
of white men fit your narrative this is
a problem here you shut up it's not
about you what is it what if it is said
that to the men before the Emancipation
Proclamation it's like I hereby sign
okay okay I'm gonna let you finish but
shut up and say that ain't about you
listen to our plight and the reason let
me get hired back to this idea that
white men shouldn't have an opinion on
abortion okay we legalize abortion shall
we re-examine roe v wade No okay well I
mean created birth control do you want
to give that one but now white men
shouldn't have an opinion on oppression
ended slavery they voted for you to have
the right to vote should we demand that
black Americans women give that right
back and vote on it because it was
mostly vote on white men until we have a
majority of black okay should we just
get rid of the welfare state because
white men instituted it no they're not
consistent on any of it and this is the
appeal to authority fallacy it's even
worse from identity politics because
they pick and choose when to follow
their own version of the rules usually
when they the any politics rules fit
their narratives so throwing historical
context into the wind here I'm a woman
therefore your your opinion is invalid
you have to listen to me because vagina
we see this
with abortion I'm black you have to
listen to me because see first phrase
I'm black we can take this and apply to
anything Yeah right
this is vissa TI trans people okay we
had someone sit down with a change my
mind why do you want to deny my reality
you and you can't no and you shouldn't
you should sit down and listen because
you're not trans okay so no one who's
trans can have an opinion or be involved
in passing legislation good luck trying
to get your super majority in the House
and Senate to get your trans issues
force through let alone the courts it's
only okay if someone lives in what does
that mean yeah you don't live in my
react there's reality right you mean I
don't live in your delusional reality
you don't know what it's like to be gay
or that's fine fine then make then make
it a rule that no straight white men can
pass any legislation that relates to
women gays blacks transgenders good luck
with your reform forget hung juries you
had hung judges if that's the case yes
half of them are gone they're completely
gone unless you've had enough of your
specified victims class status of the
day enough seats filled in the house in
the halls of government you're never
gonna see any new laws you're never
gonna have enough black women or
[ __ ] sequential hermaphrodites in
the Senate of the house nothing's ever
going to get passed did you think the
left has no intent of following through
with there are no I mean this is what
but this is the biggest logical fallacy
the left and that's why it bothers
because these are the same people by the
way who when you talk about climate
change like we've talked about you know
like the Great Lakes doing really well
unbelievable crop season so we're talkin
pragmatically actually there have been
some really beneficial effects and
through the recent temperatures which
have been remarkably temperate set in
some places in the Midwest not another
place we're not talking about whether
you believe in climate change or not
personally but these are the same people
who say well it doesn't matter what you
believe because there's a 97% consensus
on global warming so we can't have this
discussion but then they don't trust a
drop of medical research because it's
all paid off by Big Pharma and by the
way weed cures cancer of course you had
to throw that in there it's true these
are the same people yeah 7% of
scientists well what about the fact that
science is kind of out and if you want
to get high that's fine but maybe
doesn't cure cancer what are you gonna
do then inferences to one degree or
another based on sources that's why you
have to aggregate as many as many
resources as possible don't just
they should go to HuffPo go to salon go
read this go read whatever go read it
PubMed we have access to a lot of
documents because of the licenses we pay
for with this show read everything you
possibly can from both points of view of
course like a courtroom you try and find
as many expert testimonies as you can
but then acknowledge that you're making
at some point in inference and be
consistent about it when people are
saying okay there's a 97% scientific
consensus so well it's not what they're
really saying is you need to shut up you
don't have an opinion here when they say
why do you care so much about abortion
you don't have a vagina what they're
really just saying is I'm not equipped
for this argument so you better shut up
when they say shut up this isn't about
you they are quite literally just saying
shut up because I don't want to have to
argue my point logically just address
these people when they say shut up you
don't have a vagina care of an opinion
on abortion you go okay so Rovi wait
what about the male judges who they say
shut up isn't about you black lives
matter you say okay so them I guess
let's let's just just right away respond
repeal the anti-slavery law what do you
mean just fling it right back at them
you have to you have to take this crap
it's silly and I'm amazed at how many
people are stumped by it it's just as
stupid as any other appeal to authority
fallacy only less consistent hey there
youtube viewer if you like this video I
would say subscribe hit the notification
bell or watch one of these videos
playing in a box that we've personally
uploaded in program for your viewing
pleasure the problem is now in today's
day and age on YouTube in 2018
any of those three things that you do
any of those three buttons that you
click will take you directly to a Seth
Meyers video so stay here and join my
get off of here go to lateral credit I
come /mo Club it's the only safe place
you can go enjoy